AND HE HITS
NETS.
WE CALL HIM TLC IF YOU LIKE.
YOU ARE
AGAINST ORLANDO, IT'S NOT HOW
YOU PLAY IT WITH
STEPH CURRY'S THIRD THREE IS, WE
FINAL MINUTE.
CURRY.
DOWN THE LANE.
TO SEE THAT REJUVENATION REGGIE
BUCKET AND HE STILL COULDN'TD, A
BAD IDEA.
STEPH THOUGHT ABOUT TAKING THE
FLOATER OTHER SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AND IS IN A TORTURE CHAMBE
AND OUTSIDE IT ND THE THIRD ANDS
IT IN!ACK BRAERK RIGHT THERE.
NO ONE WAS AROUND HIM.ND
LANGFORD IS SMOTHEREDO ANSWER A
CANNOT.
LOOK WHO
SWITCH, BROOKS GET HIM RIGHT
HAVE MELO BALL.
THREW IT AWAY AND A A LaMELO BA
>> Bob: THE BALLLEAD.
STEP THREE.
HEMPLE, ABLE TO SNEAK
IT TO GRAHAM, MR.
BRADY.
>> Mark: LIKE A RECEIVER. MISSE
START THE
>> TALKING TO CLOSE-OUT. INSIDE.
WE'VE SEEN
THEY CAME FROM 19 DOWN TO BEAT
FIRST HALF.
VERY PHYSICAL GAME. OFF FRONT
IRON THEREOF GAMES WHERE HE WAS
STARTED TO PLAY WELINS IN THE L.
REBOUND.
DOG.
THAT'S -- YOU THINK HE IS A
JUNKYARD DOG DEFENSIVELY, SO YOU
HEARING BROWN.
CURRY WITH THELOONEY, OFFENSIVE
REBOUND,